écoutez en absolu que le président de
république et le président du sénat ce
téléphone ce n'est pas en soi un drame
institutionnels et le président du sénat
a visiblement n'a rien dit sur
l'entretien
toutefois compte tenu de l'ambiance
depuis deux jours on peut imaginer les
spéculations vont bon train
on a vu vous l'avez dit depuis deux
jours on a l'impression que la emmanuel
macron et le garde du corps de monsieur
benalla en tout cas avec il a mobilisé
la garde des sceaux sur le sujet et on
al'impression finalement qu' il faudrait
mettre un périmètre de sécurité autour
de l'elysée c'est bien juste le sujet de
cette commission denquête que d'évaluer
comment aujourd'hui le pouvoir exécutif
fonctionnent les responsabilités de
chacun et si bien entendu il n'y a pas
une prééminence de la présidence de la
république sur l'ensemble du pouvoir
exécutif qui fait qu en fait personne ne
lui résiste
et ce coup de fil illustre cela
précisément en soit écouté je n'étais
pas présente donc je ne peux pas vous
dire
donc je préfère ne pas spéculer moi ce
que je constate c'est que si le
président de la république téléphone au
président du sénat pour lui dire écouter
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de votre
institution c'est pas très correct on a
il ya une espèce de confusion
est ce que ça veut dire que c'est un pas
de plus dont le non-respect du parlement
est-ce que c'est finalement le fait de
refuser au parlement des pouvoirs de
contrôle sur l'exécutif
est-ce qu'on est à la veille d'une
démocratie libérale en france pour vous
il n'ya donc pas de déséquilibre
institutionnel qui est manifestée par
cette commission denquête on dit ah le
président de la république n'aurait pas
digéré certains propos de philippe bas
qui aurait dit que le parlement contrôle
l'exécutif
ce que ça va à l'encontre de la
séparation des pouvoirs et un entendu
nous le sait le rôle du parlement que de
contrôler l'exécutif
et s'il ya des compos s'interroger sur
le bien-fondé d'avoir des conseillers à
la fois qu'ils sont à la fois auprès du
président la république et du
gouvernement mais si le président
république a décidé ce genre de choses
c'est bien qu'ils considèrent que le
préjudice est un tout et le le parlement
n'auraient pas droit de contrôler cela
c'est une conception assez particulière
de la démocratie
oui je précise que vous étiez à
l'origine de cette question de ses
conseillers communs à edouard philippe
oui tout à fait réelle macron se lamente
pour vous une confusion des genres au
sein de la
chine de l'exécutif ça peut a montré une
est en tout cas la conception qui a
quelques montres emmanuel macron avec
cette volonté d'avoir des conseillers
commun c'est de faire bloc et qu'il n'y
ait pas de séparation entre les deux
alors qu'ils n'essayent pas maintenant
de faire de la sémantique sur un contre
l'action du gouvernement ne contrôle pas
l'elysée et l'elysée seraient quoi une
bulle sans aucun contrôle pendant cinq
ans il pourrait faire ce qu'il veut sans
aucun contrôle
je rappelle quand même que le budget de
l'elysée il est voté par le parlement
est-ce que vous pensez que la commission
denquête va trop loin on entend aussi
les accusations d'instrumentalisation de
cette commission denquête c'est là où il
faut faire attention c'est que la
commission d' enquête doit être
réellement sur les questions
institutionnelles et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui le président la
république
ils voient que finalement c'est parce
qu'on on insiste sur les
dysfonctionnements internes au pouvoir
exécutif sur le manque de contrôle sur
la prééminence du président de la
république et de la présidence et de
ceux qui peuvent s'en prévaloir
la question nous avons fait très
attention au sein de la commission
denquête à ne pas interférer sur les
actions en justice il étudie et et à
partir du moment où l'enquêté judiciaire
elle est à côté et où les droits de la
défense de monsieur b dallas ont
respecté les questions sur les
dysfonctionnements institutionnels ils
sont complètement légitime pour cette
commission denquête que je rappelle et
politique